the Trump re-election campaign kicks off
tonight in Orlando that's in Florida
thank you you know what to expect
I thought that was the Sun in my eyes
it's these stupid lights what are they
doing that runway is like an ice skating
rink and the first step I said you know
this sucker is slippery there's a worst
damn stage I've ever child cast cuckoo
but I like I Ted much better - can we go
by I tend you mind last night I watched
Alfred e Newman Beta Beta Beta us
falling fest what the hell happened I
was made for this he was made for it he
was made to fall like a rock and I don't
know what the hell happened to Biden and
Bernie you know Bernie's crazy now
compare all of that to this my name is
Joe Biden I'm running from this case
running for United States
[Music]
I will always be real with you I will be
bold without the bull yikes it's a
roller coaster versus the little pony
carousel Santa's elves versus the big
orange RINO it's a fact that Trump rally
is really fun unlike those socialist
infomercials that induced vomiting
that's because Trump's a phenomenon that
combines the powers of persuasion
Pro Wrestling reality TV and celebrity
roasts into one giant fireball it's a
historical and hysterical first but it's
also early so who knows who can match
Trump for thrills and chills but how can
the Dems have 20 candidates but not a
single clue they're meeting the Donald
with the doll here's what to consider
watching tonight's rally would any of
the energy and humor make any sense if
America wasn't doing great would any of
Trump's words feel bizarrely off if we
were in deep trouble of course but they
won't because we're not if there were
big Wars unemployment high crime a dead
economy there'd be no place for this at
all sure if you're obsessively furious
at Trump you'll say it's the worst of
times
but measures perform
using practical evidence and not his
tweet Sora's behavior it might be the
best so the rally will be fun and loud
and unpredictable because the mitigation
of other bigger problems make it so in
fact all the stuff from impeachment
blathered a media meltdowns are products
of an age when big problems are being
tackled in new ways of course millions
will love the rally millions will hate
it
and millions won't care but their
ability to happily decide is brought to
you by one sturdy fact America is better
off now that it's been in years alright
so one maybe I posed this question to
you energy isn't what American wants
after four years maybe they want a comfy
sweater maybe the Democrats are right to
come at this and maybe a more muted way
I think that's right I think that if
this is a referendum on Donald Trump
Donald Trump loses because if you look
at the polls he's underwater
he's strongly underwater so he's got a
you know Democrats have to say here's
someone who's stable someone who is
rational who doesn't tweet off crazy
stuff someone that that you can trust in
critical moments and I think that's what
that's why Joe Biden right now has
leading I think last night I already
rate he said he had 20 million bucks in
the bank so he's really raised more
money than any other Democrats so that
those are all the reasons I think the
only strategy left for Trump and I think
we'll see it tonight at the rally Greg
is for him to attack and smear his
opponent so he'll talk about the
socialist he's gonna talk about nasty
woman he's going to talk about tired
sleepy Joe that's what he has to do
because if it's just about Donald Trump
he loses so he's got a you know nasty up
his opponent to the point where people
would say well you know what I'll go
with Trump my by the way in response to
your thing you always say things are so
great if things are so great Greg why
did Democrats capture 40 seats in the
midterms why are we sending troops to
the Middle East why do you think that
it's farmers are complaining about the
lack of a trade deal and the tariffs are
driving up prices at Walmart and Costco
I mean I there's a reason people are
saying this guy is not a good pleasure
when you compare to the overall world
you Jesse low unemployment booming
economy a shrinking military footprint
while having a huge military he doesn't
necessarily have to insult to anybody he
could just go by his record
I can't believe president is going to
attack his political opponent and you
know I can't believe you know a
Republican president might lose seats in
the midterm that's never happened before
either didn't yesterday I showed you
every single person that won the
presidency since 1984 had been down in
the polls in June and they came back and
won yeah but they don't fire their
pollster the polls right now mean
nothing the poll said Hillary was going
to beat Trump poll said Hillary was
going to be trouble Florida okay and he
won by a hundred thousand votes in
Florida after being outspent 53 to one
down the stretch he's got in Florida two
Republican senators he's got a
Republican governor and the Quinnipiac
poll actually said both of those guys
DeSantis and Scott were going to lose by
seven in the midterms and they won so
the fact that that polls show from
Quinnipiac Biden beating Trump by seven
in Florida doesn't really mean much
right now the media knows there's no one
that can compete against Donald Trump
with these rallies they see the lines
they see people in tents camping out
they see the raucous connection he makes
and the crowd goes wild and they'll do
anything they can to denigrate him
because they know and Democrat can't
pull it off
so they'll go after his supporters
you'll see tonight reporters on the
ground they won't interview Hispanic or
black Trump supporters they'll look for
the craziest people with the most
radical signs and they'll actually
debate them but the ironic thing is the
more they attack the president and his
supporters the stronger that connection
gets Dana you know the only way Dems can
get people showing up in tents is by
making them homeless we'll be right back
no what do you expect tonight out of
Trump I know what you're going to say
but I want you to say for me I don't
think I don't think he should ramble I
wasn't going to say that but I agree oh
thank you no actually people love the
rambling what are you talking about Oh
I think going long I don't think you
should go long okay well I'll let you
give him that advice but like you just
showed that that montage which is
hilarious because he was rambling yeah
about things that are not they're not in
the script when he's talking about the
lights and then yeah yeah yeah or and
everything I think this um you can't
capture lightning in a bottle twice and
he's I why were them I would downplay
all comparisons to 2015 because he now
he has a record to defend and as you say
you know the record is all these amazing
great things so he can talk about those
things before he was the insurgent yeah
it was I'm gonna come in there I'm gonna
shake things up I'm going to be the
outsider and he has done all of those
things but now he also is an incumbent
and incumbency gives you so many tools
to use it is so hard to beat an
incumbent president very very difficult
if you think it's only happened twice
since World War two so I think the
polling right now it doesn't really
matter it matters for Biden because you
can figure out a way to like raise more
money but but the polls right now that
doesn't really matter you're gonna see a
lot more after the debates I would say
that um his biggest strength right now
the war chest is huge
it's got all of his money didn't have it
the first time the RNC firmly behind him
from the jump it's got a huge amount of
organization so they've got all these
get-out-the-vote pieces the numbers of
people that they can talk to people
getting their cell phones with their
pictures on it so they can send it to
their friends all that stuff they didn't
have a way to capture it before and they
do now that said it's still gonna be a
big race and there's all of these states
that they're gonna have to pay a lot of
attention to Emily bring us home with
the most most thoughtful analysis on
this network today glad to
what is so telling and also should be so
encouraging to the Trump team right now
is you know people were waiting in line
for 40 hours with us and the closest
we've ever seen to something like that
was the Obama nomination in 2008 right
at the Denver Broncos Stadium and
obviously that was media reported 75,000
Amway only holds 20,000 and obviously
this is a very different event but the
point to note is that Obama failed to
generate that kind of enthusiasm in 2012
the next time around and here we have
the incumbent with people standing in
line for 40 hours for this announcement
yep mm-hmm well that was good it was the
best analysis all day yes exactly
by the way just one point Orlando
Sentinel already ahead of the rally
issued a non endorsement without knowing
the other candidates it's not kind of
garbage on the part of a paper doesn't
that tell you something about Trump no
just know it's an emotional response
though that's an emotional response of a
paper that's why nobody likes these
papers is that that's so emot-- it's
such a delusional like oh we we don't
like him we don't care who's running
against him that's there that's the
paper if they think that they say that
they as thoughtful people there's an
editorial yeah this is an unsigned added
to a badly whole newspaper not
oncologist babies and they're saying
listen the state of the country the
divisiveness the anger they just mode
but those are all emotional issues not
practical evidence in a sense it'll
stick to the facts but anyway all right